last question today David do you think
that more people are actually allergic
to foods maybe because of environmental
factors or do you think that we're
actually causing people to have food
allergies by being overprotective
like with peanuts in schools I think
it's both actually so there are a number
of studies that have been done there
observational studies they are not
interventional studies and that's a
really important thing if you're going
to analyze a medical study you want to
be really clear about whether it's an
observational study or an interventional
study where you're actually comparing a
treatment therapy or intervention with a
placebo group and it's double-blind and
all of that stuff I've talked about
observational studies point to a few
factors for what are increased food
allergies on the behalf of children and
adults number one there's the hygiene
hypothesis okay that's the idea that
when you overly protect children from
infectious agents early in their lives
you can create a scenario where when
they finally have the peanuts at age
five or whenever or when they're finally
allowed to play in the dirt or whatever
it was that that many of us were allowed
to do the body by virtue of having not
been exposed to those individual things
elements I don't know what to call it
things sound so scientific unscientific
that the body treats those as invading
germs and that it's not so much that you
genuinely would have had a peanut
allergy had you been introduced slowly
to peanuts at an earlier age but that
because you were kept completely peanut
free for the first five years of your
life by the time you have the peanuts
your body says we've never seen this
before what is this this is a germ we
are going to react as if this is
something that is bad for us
that's one theory the other theory that
has come or hypothesis that has come
from observational studies is that
environmental changes and factors are
causing a problem here and there's sort
of two lines right one is environmental
stuff if climate warms you have longer
growing seasons for many types of plants
that cause allergies which
makes people with respiratory allergies
experienced them for longer periods of
time and that can complicate food
allergies as well and it can just
generally create worse pollen allergies
so on and so forth that's one angle the
other angle is chemicals in food right
that would be the other thing chemicals
and food chemicals in the water
chemicals in the air may be catalyzing
allergies we don't know the full scope
of it yet is basically that what we come
to but all of the above are
possibilities yeah I'm worried about
dipping my toes into this one I remember
I admitted to using a Keurig and that
sparked this year-long controversy yeah
almost pulled the show actually yeah got
kicked off the show for that so I don't
want to get involved in this one twelve
affiliates actually threatened to never
never broadcast the show again and I had
to say I had to tell him Pat was kidding
when he talked about the Keurig it's
just like he plays a character on the
air is not his name is not even really
pat forward right I mean he's producer
Pat Forde on the air but we were able to
stave off an inevitable doom for the
program as a result of yeah really I'm a
melancholy dude with the British accent
and you would never know yep no question
about it and he's not even really vegan
that's part of the character as well so
that unfortunately it's probably going
to be this I believe the food allergy
circumstance is going to be one of those
things where in 15 years we will without
a doubt know what it is that set off the
increase in adult and child food
allergies but that right now we have a
bunch of competing or possibly
complementary hypotheses thank you for
the questions if you have a question for
us send it in email voicemail Twitter
Facebook my personal Instagram the show
Instagram a trolling youtube comment a
not trolling youtube comment telegram
DHL snail mail I don't care how you send
it in we're ignoring all of them unless
their email that's my message to you
today and we will talk to you on the
bonus show